WALTER KORMAN: Hi,
I'm Walter Korman,
introducing Dr.
Anne Yoder, Director
of Duke Lemur Center presenting
to Google San Francisco today.
[APPLAUSE]
ANNE YODER: So thanks, Walter.
And thanks for having me.
I'm really psyched to be here
in San Francisco at Google.
I've been a fan of Google's
for a long time, of course.
We all are.
So it's great to be here.
So I am going to give
you a talk today.
"Madagascar's Mouse
Lemurs as a Model System
for Investigating
Speciation, Climate Change,
and (Possibly
Alzheimer's Disease)."
So as Walter has
heard via e-mail,
it's about four or five talks
kind of squished into one.
So I hope I pull it off.
So for the outline
of the talk, what
you can expect to hear--
first, to understand lemurs,
you have to
understand Madagascar.
So they're intertwined
inextricably.
So we'll look at
Madagascar for a bit first.
And then we'll
focus in on lemurs
and why they're so special.
And I'm a Grateful
Dead fan, so what
a long, strange trip
it's been is a theme.
Species diversity in mouse
lemurs is not about us.
And you'll, hopefully,
get that message
when we get to that
part of the talk.
And as a side note, we'll
have a little diversion.
So mostly, I do
evolutionary genetics.
And I'm interested in
island biogeography
and evolutionary change.
But as Director of
the Lemur Center,
I've also been drawn
into Alzheimer's disease,
surprisingly.
And I'll explain how that
happened when we get there.
OK, we'll also talk about
climate change and lemurs
on the move.
So we all know that climate
change is a real thing.
And it's having profound
impacts everywhere
on people and organisms.
And it's looking
like it will have
serious impacts for lemurs.
And so we'll look at that.
That will lead us
into conservation
in action, or corridor science.
And then, what can
mouse lemurs tell us
about Madagascar's past?
And finally, just as a
little side end note,
what does any of this
have to do with Google?
And you will see.
So first of all, you
know where you are.
We're here in California.
So we're going to go quite
a distance around the planet
to Madagascar.
So it's right off the
coast of East Africa,
as you probably know.
And it's a fascinating
place to do research,
because it's not a
continent, really.
But it's not really
an island, either.
So it obeys some of the
rules of continents,
but it breaks most of them.
It obeys some of the
rules of islands,
but it breaks a lot of them.
So it's a complicated
place to work.
And that's why it's so much fun.
For one thing,
I've done some back
of the envelope calculations.
And Madagascar comprises 0.01%
of Earth's land surface area.
So that's just a speck,
really, on the planet.
But when you then look
at species diversity,
and lemurs particularly,
you find that almost 20%
of primate species diversity
is found on this island, which
is roughly the size
of California--
so again, the California theme.
So that's a lot-- 20%
of primate species found
on this one speck of earth.
Why is that?
Well, hopefully I'll
explain a little of that.
And another aspect
of lemurs that I
think you probably are
aware of is that they
are highly endangered.
And in fact, they've
been designated
as the most endangered
vertebrates on Earth--
not just mammals,
not just primates,
but vertebrates on earth.
So to be a lemur is to
be critically endangered.
So I'm going to give
you a little bit more
of a visual about what
that will look like.
This is a circos diagram.
I don't know if anybody's
aware of circos diagrams.
For you computer
persons out there,
you might want to look into it.
It's an amazing tool for
visualizing very complex data.
So if you can't really
plot it on a graph,
circos diagrams are
a great way to look
at these multi-dimensional
data sets.
But what you see
here is on the top,
you see the IUCN
status-- so data
deficient, critical, endangered,
vulnerable, et cetera.
And on the bottom, you see
all the species of lemur
and grouped by their lineages.
So if we look at
least concern, we
see there are only
three species out
of all of these species of
lemur that are doing well.
Nearly threatened-- just a few,
vulnerable-- quite a bit more,
endangered-- it gets pretty
hairy, critically endangered--
a lot of them, and then we
have some other species that we
don't know much about at all.
So there is still
a lot that we can
learn about a lot of
species out there.
And when you look
at it all together,
you see that the hot colors
kind of rule the map here.
So that's a more detailed look
at this critically endangered
designation for lemurs.
OK, so this is where we're going
to get a sense of Madagascar's
place on the planet
in sort of time,
and how the earth has changed.
So what you're seeing at
the very top of the screen
is a time ticker.
It started at 200
million years ago.
We're approaching the present.
And what you're seeing is
the break-up of Gondwana.
Now that green
spot that you see--
that is the break-up of
Laurasia and Gondwana.
And if you look down, you'll see
Madagascar sort of tucked in.
I don't know if I can
use my mouse to show you.
Yes, so here's Madagascar.
It's adjacent to India.
And it's drifting
away from Africa here.
So this is Africa.
This is South America.
And up here is Laurasia.
So at about 130
million years ago,
it separated
completely from Africa.
It stays connected to India for
some 30 million years or so.
We're going to just
watch it moving around.
And at about 88 million
years, pay close attention,
because that's when
India actually separates
from Madagascar and
hightails it across what
is known-- all
right, here we go--
hightails it across what we
know as the Indian Ocean.
And now you know why it's
called the Indian Ocean--
because India traversed
this body of water
about 70 million years ago.
And in a moment, you'll
see a burst of black.
And that's it going
over the Deccan Traps.
This is a hot spot.
This accelerates
India's movement,
and then you see it here
colliding with Asia.
And so this is what
built the Himalayas.
And it's a very
active tectonic area,
as you know, from
recent history.
So anyway, the point,
though, being that here's
Madagascar all by its lonesome
for a very long time--
80 million years,
88 million years.
So that begs the question, how
did lemurs get to Madagascar
in the first place?
And that was actually
the initial work
that I did in lemurs,
was to try to determine
how many times they got there,
when, and by what mechanisms.
And so I'm just going to
very quickly summarize
that information.
And I can tell you they
got there just once.
So they are a single clade.
They had an ancestral
form that arrived there
at some point in time.
We've actually done
those calculations,
and it was about 60
million years ago.
And so they arrived in
Madagascar 60 million years
ago, one time, and
all kinds-- you know,
evolution has happened in
those 60 million years.
So here we have,
what does earth look
like at about the
time that lemurs would
have arrived in Madagascar?
And you can see that
India is here, separated.
Madagascar has been separated
from Africa for a long time.
So the only option, it
seems, is open water.
So if you study
biogeography, there
are various categories of
how animals and plants have
gotten around the planet.
There's something
called vicariance.
And what that would mean would
be that lemurs were already
there in Madagascar when it
separated from these other land
masses.
But we now know that that
was-- it's way too old
for that to have happened.
Another option is a land
bridge or island hopping,
so that there would
have been some kind
of terrestrial
mechanism where they
would have traversed from Africa
or India over to Madagascar.
I won't go through
all the details.
I have a couple of
papers out on this,
but we have ruled that out.
So we are left with what
George Gaylord Simpson called
"sweepstakes" dispersal,
which is just like Hail Mary
and build me a raft.
So how did that happen?
That's one of the
other questions
that I've asked myself.
So this is a database
from the World Bank
that tracks cyclone paths.
And you can see
here, poor Madagascar
just gets slammed by cyclones.
And so these are all
cyclones from recent history.
And what happens is
the cyclones tend
to come across from the east
across the Indian Ocean.
They're picking up
steam as they go.
They hit Madagascar,
sweep over it,
then they bounce off of the
thermal inertia of Africa,
and sweep back across.
So often, Madagascar
will get slammed twice.
I know, it's awful.
So Madagascar really gets
hammered by these cyclones.
And it has a huge impact today.
But I know as an
evolutionary biologist,
it's very dangerous to take
things that are occurring today
and apply them to the past.
You really want to verify that.
So of course, you can make up a
story given what we know today.
And actually, when these
cyclones do happen,
people have observed giant
rafts of vegetation out
in the middle of the Mozambique
Channel with standing trees,
because it's so violent.
And they're ripping
river banks apart.
So conceivably,
that could explain
how lemurs and other
organisms could have gotten
from Africa to Madagascar.
But again, it's
a dangerous thing
to take these
present-day phenomena
and apply them to the past.
And also, notably, the currents
today flow from the east
to the west.
So they would be in
the opposite direction
of what would facilitate rafting
from Africa to Madagascar.
But in 2010, this
very cool paper
was published by Ali
and Huber in "Nature."
And I actually
reviewed the paper.
And I could sort of almost see
the smile on the editor's face
when he asked me to
review this paper.
But they did a
computer simulation
where they placed
all the continents
in the places they would
have been back in the Eocene.
And they recreated the climate,
and the ocean currents,
and so on.
And it was this long simulation.
It took a very long time to run.
And this was six years ago,
so computers were much slower.
But the punch line was
that ocean currents would
have flown from west to east.
And there would have been
these episodic storms, where
rafts could have been moved very
rapidly across the Mozambique
Channel.
So it kind of
provided the mechanism
that I'd been searching
for for much of my career.
And layer on top of that-- some
anecdotal observations in other
primates that, in times of
great duress, where they have
to endure extreme climate
or food deprivation, torpor
or hibernation can be
induced episodically.
So can anybody see the
mammal in this picture?
There it is.
This is a paper that
was published in 2013,
led by the postdoc
the Duke Lemur Center,
Marina Blanco, who has
discovered-- well, we
knew already that some lemurs
hibernate for about half
of the year.
These are the dwarf lemurs.
They're very closely
related to mouse lemurs.
And she was the one to
discover that they actually
hibernate underground.
So I'm going to--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-show you a great little film.
[SPEAKING MALAGASY]
ANNE YODER: You get
to hear some Malagasy.
[SPEAKING MALAGASY]
ANNE YODER: He's pissed.
[END PLAYBACK]
ANNE YODER: So anyway, this
is pretty amazing stuff.
So there are dwarf
lemurs closely
related to the mouse lemurs that
hibernate for half of the year.
They go underground.
And Marina has been radio
collaring these animals,
and then following them--
finding them when they're
hibernating underground.
And we've been doing genetic
analyses of their gene
expression profiles when
they're hibernating,
and what's driving that.
And that's a whole
another story of its own.
But anyway, so here
we have, I think,
the mechanism that might explain
how lemurs got to Madagascar.
So it does appear that it
was an over-water dispersal,
and perhaps facilitated by
hibernation or the ability
to torpor, and
certainly, probably,
facilitated by this ocean
current and these storms.
So lemurs got to
Madagascar just once.
They got there a long time ago.
And everything that's
happened since then
has been localized
to Madagascar.
And so this is kind
of what it looks like.
So this is a phylogeny.
You can see that the ancestral
node in the phylogeny
here is about 60 million years.
And then there's a
sort of long pause
where we get this secondary
radiation at about 40
million years ago.
And again, this is
its own seminar.
But I believe this is
related to climate change.
When India got out of the
way of Madagascar and thus
set up these trade
winds, and would
have set up the eastern
rainforest and the dry west,
which we'll hear more
about in just a little bit.
OK, so moving on-- so Madagascar
has had this strange history.
And lemurs got there.
And they've been
doing their thing,
and other critters and plants
have been doing their thing
all this time.
And many of us who
study Madagascar
think of it as sort of
a speciation laboratory.
And there are multiple,
multiple studies
of different vertebrates
and plants, and even birds,
that show that groups
that get to Madagascar
tend to get there just
once and then radiate.
So you have this really
interesting pattern
of diversity, but
endemism to Madagascar.
So they're unique to Madagascar.
So what is that about?
My career has, more and more,
become focused on mouse lemurs.
And I hope you will
see why as I go on.
But they're just
endlessly fascinating.
So a lot has changed just in
the last couple of decades.
So in 1993, we thought
we knew a bunch of things
about mouse lemurs.
We knew that there were just
two species of mouse lemurs, one
from the west
coast of Madagascar
and one from the east,
that they were very similar
morphologically and
ecologically, and probably
only recently diverged,
that they both have
broad geographic distributions.
They both readily adapt
to secondary habitat.
And in fact, this is
a very cool thing.
If you go to Madagascar, you
can go to almost any village.
And if the weather is
right, you can go out
at night with your headlamp.
And if there's some scrubby
little forest outside,
even if it's very degraded, you
can go out with your headlamp,
and you see the mouse lemurs
jumping around in the trees.
And you see their eye shine.
It's just awesome.
So they adapt to
secondary habitat.
And all of this put
together-- back then,
it was assumed that
mouse lemurs were not
under any threat of extinction.
Because they were
all over the place.
They got along pretty well
in this secondary habitat,
and they were doing well.
Well, a lot has
changed in 20 years.
So just by a year
ago, over the course
of these couple of
decades, work that
has been ongoing--
including a lot of my work--
has shown that species diversity
is actually very high, and is,
in fact, the highest
of all lemurs
in the mouse lemur radiation.
And you can see from this
picture that kind of one mouse
lemur looks like another.
And I think you can, literally,
have one species in one hand
and another species
in the other hand,
and not be able to
tell them apart.
So how do we do that?
Well so I got into
this in the year 2000,
or actually about
a year before that,
when a colleague of
mine, Steve Goodman,
was working with a
Malagasy graduate
student, [? Rodan ?]
[INAUDIBLE], who
had been collecting mouse
lemurs in Western Madagascar,
and was convinced that he
was seeing species diversity.
Because he was looking very
carefully at their morphology,
and what they were doing
in nature, and so on.
And so Steve said,
we want to send you
a bunch of tissue
samples so that you
can prove this genetically.
And again, this is another
seminar altogether.
But species concepts
are very complicated
and very controversial.
So it freaked me out to
think about trying to prove
that they were species.
But I thought, well, I can't
turn down all these samples
from Madagascar.
So I plunged in.
And long story
short, it turned out
that the genetic diversity
that we uncovered
was incredible, and
was shocking to me.
And from that moment
on-- so this was,
what, 16 years ago-- I
haven't really looked back.
One of the interesting
things that we found
was that the
distribution of the mouse
lemurs and their
evolutionary history
did not obey what
I was expecting
to see based on the sort
of ecotypes and geology
of Madagascar.
So that's a long story short.
And this slide is just sort
of a little cautionary tale.
Be careful what you say
in the published form,
because it has legs sometimes.
So I said, so we found
these various results.
And I said, "This
result cast doubt
on the traditional ecogeographic
models, whereas also suggesting
that species diversity may be
underestimated for eastern as
well as for western
mouse lemurs."
And so just with
that one sentence,
I now get cited as Yoder's
ecogeographic model,
which is not a model at all.
There are no
parameters whatsoever.
It just was a word
that made sense to me.
And there was a virtual
stampede of activity
in eastern Madagascar--
people going out
to look for these same kinds of
patterns of genetic diversity.
And it was really
quite a heyday.
And for a while there, every
new mouse lemur species that
came out, the press went wild.
And it was just a little nutty.
And understandably,
a lot of more
traditional primatologists, who
perhaps are not geneticists,
have been in great alarm.
And this is called
"splitting" when you do this.
When you take what
is one species
and you split it into multiple
species, that's splitting.
There are splitters and
lumpers, just so you know.
So there was a lot of concern
that we were over-splitting
the mouse lemurs.
But I'm here to tell you that we
have not over-split-- that they
really are different species.
And this is where the "it's
not about us" comes in.
Because who cares?
Would a mouse lemur care
that we can tell them apart,
or do they care that they
can tell themselves apart?
So that's sort of the point
of the next part of the talk.
So there was a very nice
paper published recently
in the journal "Evolution"
about species diversity
and how you recognize it
just in a general sense.
But I love this figure.
On the y-axis, we have
genetic divergence.
And on the x-axis, we have
morphological divergence.
And so we're up here in
this top left corner,
where it's non-adaptive
radiations or cryptic species
complexes, which are problematic
but conceptually interesting,
according to this author.
And the reason
being is, something
is driving
diversification and sort
of evolutionary unique
pathways so that they diverge,
and they keep diverging,
and they stay diverged.
But we don't know
what's driving it.
And we don't have the
sort of visual signals
to help us recognize that.
So this is cryptic species.
And mouse lemurs are
classic, I think,
cases of cryptic species.
And so here's just
a random assemblage
of six mouse lemur species.
And can you tell them apart?
Probably not.
They're all about this big.
They're brown.
They're nocturnal.
And one looks like another.
I think this is part
of the reason why
we can't see the difference.
They're nocturnal animals.
So they don't have
the same requirements
for visual communication
that we have.
So many anthropoid
primates-- which is us--
monkeys, apes, humans-- we
are very visual creatures.
So visual communication
is for breeding,
for hanging out--
anything you can think of.
Visual communication
is very important.
For a nocturnal animal,
probably not as much.
So I think we can rule out
sight as an important signaling
device for mouse lemurs,
leaving us with sound and smell.
So there's a German group
led by Elke Zimmerman who
has been looking very
carefully at mouse lemur calls,
and has discovered that
the male mouse lemurs have
very distinctive calls.
So the other calls,
like the maternal calls,
contact calls--
they're pretty similar.
But the male calls
are quite different.
And so we have here
Microcebus rufus and murinus.
And this was long enough ago
so that all we can say really
is that one was from the east
and one was from the west.
And if we look at the
male advertisement call,
sort of sounds like chirp,
chirp if you're the eastern guy.
And if you're the western
guy, it's more sort of a buzz.
And now, we're going
to have, actually,
an acoustic
experience of our own.
So this, what I've
shown you down here--
this is the mitochondrial
phylogeny of these animals--
the mitochondrial gene tree.
And so this is the species
here, Microcebus murinus.
And we're going to hear
what his call sounds like.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
[ANIMAL CALLS]
ANNE YODER: And now we're going
to go to a different address
in the phylogeny.
And this is a lehilahytsara
which you're going
to hear quite a bit more about.
[ANIMAL CALLS]
ANNE YODER: So they're almost
like songbirds, really,
where the males have these
very different calls.
[ANIMAL CALLS]
[END PLAYBACK]
ANNE YODER: This
one always makes
me think of the Larson cartoon
about the mating calls,
shows the guy in the bar at
the end-- hey baby, hey baby.
That is a great cartoon.
Gary Larson always gets it.
So anyway, I just want to thank
Elke Zimmerman for sending me
these audio tapes
to play for you.
OK, so that's Elke's work.
And so I think we can
say with some security
that mouse lemurs-- these
different species are using
different calls to advertise, to
find the right date, basically,
so that the girls
know which guys
they want to hang out with.
What we've been
doing in my lab is
we're very interested in the
more olfactory and pheromonal
communication that
they might be using.
So we have sort of dug
into this gene family,
which is called the vomeronasal
receptor 1 group, which
are these proteins that
receive olfactory or pheromonal
signals.
So they're G
protein-coupled receptors.
And you can see that the
pheromones come here.
They bind to these tissues.
And then signals are
sent to the brain
to tell the animal
what the pheromone is.
And there's a growing knowledge
about specific gene function,
like you can actually
say, OK, this gene
responds to this pheromone
in mice-- but only in mice.
So what we did is we just
kind of did a shotgun approach
to see what kind of
vomeronasal receptor genes
were present in lemurs, and
particularly mouse lemurs.
And we got a very
surprising result
in that-- just to
cut to the chase--
that there's a specific
group of this gene family
that is specific
to strepsirhines,
which are the lemurs and their
close relatives the lorises.
So we call this the
V1R strep gene family.
And I've never been able
to name a new species,
but I did name a gene family.
So that's kind of fun.
But so just backing
up, in mice--
this is a phylogenetic tree
of these different genes.
And this group has actually
been able to determine
what the specific functions
are of a particular cluster
of these genes.
So in this example,
this is V1R subfamily
is receptive only to the stimuli
from female mouse bedding.
So that is the only thing.
So female mouse bedding
and those receptors fire,
but nothing else will
excite those receptors.
But if you look at
this one, this one
responds to female
mouse bedding,
snake bedding, ferret bedding.
And there are some
that are so specific,
it's only specific to
snakes, or it's only--
so it's really quite elegant.
However a lot of mice--
who are very cute,
but people tend not
to mind killing mice.
So a lot of mice lost
their lives in this study.
And with the mouse
lemurs, we can't do that,
because they're endangered.
And we're just not going
to hurt our mouse lemurs.
So I am actually
collaborating with a guy who
is a specialist in these
olfactory and pheromonal
receptor gene families,
Hiro Matsunami at Duke.
And we are using transgenics.
So we are taking the
sequences from mouse lemurs,
and we're going
to-- I mean, this
is work that's going
on as we speak--
put these sequences
in transgenic mice
so that we can then determine
what it is that gets
these particular genes going.
And so I was asking Hiro what
we could expect from this study.
And he said, this is
probably too much to ask,
but it would be super-exciting
if, for example,
the transgenic mouse
started attacking or mating
with a castrated mouse painted
with lemur soil beddings.
So we're going to have-- it's
going to be kind of a fun ride
to see what we can find out.
And in fact, in
Greensboro, North Carolina,
which is very close
to where my lab is,
they actually have
fossa, which are
the natural predators
of mouse lemurs,
or one of the natural predators
of mouse lemurs in Madagascar.
So we're going to
experiment to see
if they respond
differently to fossa scent
than, say, wolf or something.
So it's going to be a good time.
OK, how about
Alzheimer's disease?
So we're drilling a bit deeper
into the biomedical sciences.
So it has been
known for some time
that mouse lemurs
get a disease that's
very much like Alzheimer's
disease in humans.
And there are a lot of sort
of indicators that it's
the same kind of disease.
And namely, they get plaques
and tangles like humans do.
They also get cognitive decline.
It's age related.
So there are all
these similarities
to Alzheimer's
disease in humans.
And they are the only
non-human primates
that we know of that get
this kind of disease.
And people have been looking
for Alzheimer's models.
In mice, you can induce
an Alzheimer's-like, using
transgenic tools, you can
induce something that is similar
to Alzheimer's disease.
But they are so phylogenetically
diverged from humans
and primates that it's really
not an effective model.
So we're thinking that mouse
lemurs might potentially
be ultimately an effective
drug-testing model, if nothing
else, for looking into this.
So we are collaborating
with this guy, Alan Roses,
who has devoted his
entire career into trying
to understand the underlying
genetics of Alzheimer's
disease.
And he's got a very rich
career, and a long paper
trail of very insightful work.
One of the genes that has been
implicated in Alzheimer's is
something called tom40.
Again, I could give
a whole talk on this.
But I'm just going to
scoot right to the point.
So tom40 is implicated
in something
that's called late onset
Alzheimer's disease,
or LOAD is the acronym for this.
And this is one of the
reasons that people
have been so
puzzled and thwarted
in understanding
Alzheimer's disease.
It doesn't appear to be
linked to any genetic defects,
or there are no
familiar patterns,
so it just comes up
sort of spontaneously.
It's by far the most common
form of Alzheimer's, and it
occurs in 90% of
Alzheimer's sufferers.
So there's early-onset
Alzheimer's disease
that does have a strong
genetic component.
But late onset does not.
So that's always been a puzzle.
But the configuration of
the tom40 allele in humans
has been shown to have a
statistical association
with developing this late
onset Alzheimer's disease.
So what we've been doing is
looking into the similarities
between humans and mouse
lemurs at the tom40 locus,
to see if we can see
any kind of smoking gun.
And unfortunately, we have.
It's very exciting.
And in fact, we have some
intellectual property rights
filings on the results
that we have uncovered.
And actually, when I say
"we," Peter Larson, who's
the head postdoc in my lab--
he's really led this work
and had some deep insights.
But I can't tell you,
because I'd have to kill you.
So it's proprietary right
now, but it's very exciting.
But just to sort of give
you a hint of this-- so
what you see here is
this is a phylogeny.
Here's an aye-aye and a
black and white ruffed lemur,
ring-tailed lemur.
Here's a dwarf lemur
and a mouse lemur.
And this is a gel that shows
you the size of the tom40 allele
that we're looking at.
And you see that the ancestral
form, if you go up here
to this node in the
phylogeny, would
have been this very short form.
But if you look at mouse and
dwarf lemurs, it's quite a bit
longer.
And if you compare that to
human, it's quite similar.
And we've dug down into it
to look at the similarities.
And that's what has
led us to this insight
that I think certainly speaks
to mechanism, and potentially
to a treatment.
So hopefully, you'll hear a
lot more about that going down
the road.
And this is one of
the great things
about having the
Duke Lemur Center, is
we have a colony of mouse
lemurs where we can study them,
and watch what happens
to them as they age.
And for a primate,
they age quite rapidly.
They reproduce within
the first year.
They have babies
every single year.
And they go from sort
of early middle age
at four years old to old age
at seven or eight years old,
and by 10, they're ancient.
So you can see this
progress very rapidly.
Also, we keep up with their
pedigrees very carefully.
So if we see symptoms
appearing in various lineages,
that would tell us about
potential genetic effects.
So it's a great resource for
understanding this disease.
OK, and finally, one
of the big projects
that we have going
on right now is
we're working on a genome
assembly for mouse lemur.
So we all know that
the human genome has
been sequenced and assembled.
And you would
think it's perfect.
It's not.
Genomes are very
complicated business,
and there's a lot of
bioinformatics involved.
So you'd probably
be pretty interested
if you dug down into it.
But so Drosophila,
zebrafish, human--
there are really very
few genomes out there
that are of
chromosome-level quality.
And we are almost there
with the mouse lemur.
And we've been working
with the Baylor group--
the Human Genome Sequencing
Center at Baylor.
And it's a collaboration
between the Duke Lemur Center
and Baylor.
And we're nearly there.
This figure will be sort of
hard for you to understand.
But this was the genome that
was available in green up
to about six years
ago-- 2x coverage
meaning that every base pair
on average is sequenced twice.
And then the Baylor group had
done some deep sequencing,
and so they have 100x coverage,
meaning that every base pair is
sequenced on average 100 times.
And we have taken that--
we meaning my lab.
And we've used optical mapping
and some other really dazzling
techniques.
Again, everything
is changing so fast.
And we have, as you
can see, we have vastly
improved on the length
of the scaffold.
So that tells you how
close you're getting
to an actual chromosome.
And when you see this
sort of flat top,
that means you've
gotten to the end.
So we're almost there,
to the chromosome level.
OK, now taking sort of
a big step back-- so
that was like drilling
down into sort
of biomedical potential
of mouse lemurs,
and just a whole
frontier that awaits,
and we're going down that path.
But we're also--
and particularly I
am-- very interested in what
has happened in Madagascar.
What has evolution done there?
And what does the future hold?
Because as you've heard,
it's a special place.
Lemurs have been there
for 60 million years.
They've been evolving
and diversifying.
When they're gone, that's it.
There's no going back.
So it's a critical concern of
mine-- keeping them around,
keeping them on the planet.
So what this is, is a
classic paper from 1990.
And it shows you here sort of
before man, original forest
cover in the east.
And then by the 1950s,
how degraded it is.
And this is 1984--
yet further degraded.
And today, even worse.
So with a postdoc, Jason Brown,
we wanted to look at-- OK,
so it's bad.
How bad is it going to get in
the face of climate change?
Because slash and burn
agriculture and subsistence
farming is basically what
has driven deforestation up
to this point.
But now we're going to layer
on top of that climate change.
Just what impacts is
that going to have?
And we all know-- this
is no news to anybody
here-- the world's
climate is changing fast.
You can see just in
the past 30 years,
the average global
temperatures annually
escalating very rapidly.
And I think--
certainly in my view--
it is without controversy that
this is human-mediated change.
So what our goal was, was
to compare past, present,
and future distributions
of as many lemur species
as we could using something
called species distribution
modeling, or SDM.
And this is a
geospatial technique.
And I'm going to race
through how this works,
but it's a very
powerful technique
for understanding the
appropriate environment
for a given species to occur.
So how does it work?
How do you do SDM?
Well, you start with
your lemurs here.
And you have their
locality data.
And then you estimate the
climatic variables by locality.
And there are various databases
that allow you to do this.
And so you have things
like annual precipitation,
mean temperature, isothermality,
et cetera, et cetera.
They're very complex
measures of climate.
So it's not just
rainfall and temperature.
There's a lot into it.
So you measure that
by the locality.
Then you do some very fancy
calculations, plugging it
into the black box.
And then this generates
a probability model
of species distributions.
And so hot colors
mean that the organism
that you're interested in
is very likely to occur.
There cool colors
mean not very likely.
So let's take a look.
And then you repeat this.
So this is using
today's climate.
And then you repeat this, but
you project into the future
under the assumptions
of climate change.
And for our data,
we had 3,377 points,
which actually isn't a lot.
But these are lemurs,
so it's always hard.
A lot of data from
museums and this-- I
just want to shout
out-- "Lemur News"
is a very small publication
that's organized by some very
wonderful and devoted people.
It's a great place
for Malagasy students
to publish data that
would not be published
in a peer-reviewed journal.
But it's an amazing
resource for, I saw a lemur
x in this forest.
And only "Lemur News"
will publish this.
But so Jason Brown, the
postdoc in question,
spent a full year going through
every issue of "Lemur News,"
and culling from every
issue of "Lemur News"
all the locality data
for all these species.
So it was really
quite remarkable.
I don't think anybody
else will ever
do this, or anything like it.
And then there's a
database WorldClim, which
has temperature, and rainfall,
and all these other climate
measures for around the globe.
So we used that as our source.
And to get to the
chase, what we found--
and we were using a
model for the year 2080,
and there are all sorts of
different climate models.
So we used one that was
sort of intermediate.
It's not the Doomsday,
and it's not the oh,
everything is going to be fine.
It's sort of somewhere
there in the middle.
And we found that there are
some areas of Madagascar that
will remain stable, some
areas, actually, where
lemur species will
expand their ranges,
but a lot of areas where
they will contract-- mostly
along these eastern rainforests.
And so what we did was
compile all this information,
and condense it, and identify
those parts of Madagascar
that are going to be
particularly profoundly
affected by climate change.
And it turns out that
the real hot spot
is sort of this
northeastern corridor
here that you can see
in the bright red.
So that, in our view,
should be a place
that we should really be
paying a lot of attention to,
particularly making sure that
there are forest corridors.
Because what this means is--
this is only in 60 years.
Evolution cannot operate
on that kind of time scale,
so this is fast.
And lemurs are going
to want to move.
And if they don't have the means
to get there through forest
corridors, it's a dead end.
So we are now very
cognizant of making sure
that there are
forest connections
between these major
chunks of forest,
that there are these
corridors, so that the lemurs
and associated flora
and fauna can move.
And I just want to call
out to Jason Brown, who
did all this work.
He's super.
OK, so that's sort of
the fast and dirty story
about climate change.
Lemurs are going to move.
The northeast corridor or the
northeast region of Madagascar
is going to be
particularly affected.
So this is all climate change.
But we can't forget
that day in, day out,
there is burning going on.
There is subsistence farming.
There are no bad guys.
These are people just
trying to make a living
and feed their families.
So it's a very
complicated problem.
And one has to work very
much at the grassroots level
to make a difference,
because it's people's lives
we're talking about.
So we have a project.
And it is just coincidental
that our project site
is very close to
this area that we
identified as being so critical
in the face of climate change.
It's called the Duke Lemur
Center SAVA Conservation
Initiative.
And it's up in the northeast
part of Madagascar.
There are two protected forests.
And when I say protected,
that's on paper.
It's much harder to enforce than
it is in other places with more
resources.
But you'll notice that there's
a big forest here called
Marojejy.
It's a mountain.
It's spectacular.
It's a UNESCO World
Heritage site.
And then there's a place
I can't pronounce here
further to the south.
And you'll see there's no
protected area connecting them.
I mean, that's one thing
that jumps out at you.
So let's take a look
using Google Earth,
and see what this looks like.
And wow.
What do you see, but there's
a corridor right there
that's connecting these two.
And this was filmed just
recently, so it's still there.
So here are the two
protected areas.
And now our target
is very clear--
that we want to protect this
corridor, which currently
does not have protected status.
And there are villages
encroaching on either side.
And you can see, actually,
here how degraded the habitat
on either side to the
north and the south side
of this corridor.
So we're going to be working
with the Madagascar National
Parks to just delineate
this corridor, and also
these other protected areas.
So this is something that's
very important for going forward
to protect these
forest corridors.
So now, shifting
gears yet again--
so I wanted to know
if mouse lemurs might
be sort of like a
canary in the coal mine
in determining when forests are
just on the verge of collapse.
Because the thinking was,
OK, you've got a forest.
It can't support the
big lemurs anymore.
But maybe it can still
support mouse lemurs.
And if you go there, and you
can't even find mouse lemurs,
then you know that
it is sort of gone,
and it needs, then, intensive
reforestation, or forest
restoration, or
whatever mechanism
you want to think about.
But it's a way to determine
the health of the forest.
So Marina Blanco that
I mentioned earlier,
who is the one who
studies this hibernation
pattern in the dwarf lemurs--
I sent her on a mission.
And I said, just go
everywhere, and see how many
mouse lemurs you can collect.
And see if they're
the only lemurs there,
or if there are other lemurs.
Let's just have a
first look at this.
And so she did.
And she went to five field
sites, collected 29 mouse
lemurs, seven dwarf lemurs, four
flights, and 4,200 kilometers
by road.
And so this is a problem
I face in the sort
of evolutionary literature--
in that people who are studying
crickets can go out
and collect thousands
of crickets in their backyard.
And so we're interested
in mouse lemurs.
Not only do we have to go all
the way around the planet,
and go to these
extreme measures.
It's really hard to get around,
even once you get there.
So these are my own pictures
from previous field work.
There are no bridges.
So you have to find another
way to get across a stream.
This is what air travel
looks like in Madagascar.
And this is a
Madagascar traffic jam,
which these occur with
alarming frequency.
So the fact that she
went to five sites
and did all this
work in three months
is really quite remarkable.
And this is one of
these things that I
love about science--
you just never know
what's going to happen.
So at the end of her
expedition, and she'd
been to all these
very remote places,
she said, "Then, depending on
the return date to the USA,
I'll try to fit another short
expedition to Ankafobe to try
to get mouse and dwarf lemurs."
She is basically
saying, is that OK?
And she said, this
is this little place.
It's an hour north of Tana,
which is the main city.
And if you fly from
anywhere else in on earth,
you fly into Tana.
So I thought, yeah,
sure, why not?
Drive up there, take an hour.
So I said, sure, go for it.
Well, it's quite remarkable.
So here we go--
Google Earth again.
So this is Ankafobe.
And it's a tiny, little place.
So you can see it's one
kilometer in length,
and it's just nothing, really.
And the other green that you
see-- these are rice paddies.
So this is really a
very special place
left in this highland plateau,
that's still forested.
And this sort of
gives you the view
of what Ankafobe looks like.
And it's sort of a
moonscape environment.
Now the amazing thing is--
so we got these samples back
to the lab.
We generated some genetic data.
And we took a look.
And amazingly, in this
tiny, little forest patch,
you would expect that it would
be monotypic genetically,
because you would
think inbreeding,
and these little animals
have been trapped there
for a long time.
And instead, the
genetic diversity
was the highest at that
locality of any locality
that she sampled.
So that's when we all
took a step back and said,
what is going on here?
So that started--
that was in December.
And we've been on
just kind of a mission
ever since to try to
get this figured out.
For one thing, before Marina
collected these samples,
this one species is called
lehilahytsara, which
means Goodman's, or good man.
So it's named after
Steve Goodman.
So it was thought to be sort of
a rainforest edge specialist,
because the very
few samples that
had been collected
previously had all
been collected sort of on
the edge of the rainforest.
And you can see that,
well, here's Ankafobe here.
So it's quite a bit
to the west of what
had been previously collected.
So we have now revised
our view of this animal
from being a forest edge
specialist to being a plateau
specialist.
And this is the first
lemur ever to have
been determined as potentially
a plateau specialist.
Because the plateau now pretty
much looks like a moonscape,
as you saw.
So I just want to give you
sort of an overview of what
Madagascar looks like-- the
environmental heterogeneity.
So you'll see that on the
east coast, it's very steep.
This is where India
used to connect.
It's rain forest.
And then there's this sort of
highland plateau in the middle
that is the moonscape.
And then it gradually goes
down to sea level on the west.
And there is continuous--
or at one time,
there was continuous--
sort of dry deciduous
and spiny forest along the west.
So it's quite distinct, the
east and the west, and then
this highland plateau, which
is right in the middle.
And again, thinking way back
to the beginning of the talk,
this is why I was so sure that
the eastern mouse lemurs would
be more closely
related to each other,
and the western mouse lemurs.
But we found
something different.
So that's Madagascar's
environmental heterogeneity
in a hurry.
So this has all raised
so many questions.
Is lehilahytsara
sort of a smoking gun
for east-west
corridors of the past?
Because that was
the work from 2000,
is that I found that there
were close connections
between eastern and
western mouse lemurs.
And I was baffled by this.
I just couldn't get
my head around that.
And I've been worrying
about it ever since.
When did their
diversification commence?
Have they been living on
this moonscape environment?
How long?
What will the patterns
of their gene flow look
like among and within
the populations?
And are these relic forest
museums of genetic diversity,
which is what the data
indicates so far, because there
is such high genetic diversity
in this tiny, little place.
So it was a great, big puzzle.
And this is sort of
the most recent work
that I'm presenting.
So it's still very
much hypothetical.
So just again to
refresh your memory
about the environmental
heterogeneity in Madagascar--
so we have eastern
rainforest here in the green.
We have this dry, deciduous
forest in the blue.
And then here is this highland
plateau, which at this point
is just this vacant
grassland with just
little bits of forest.
So the traditional hypothesis
of Madagascar's deforestation
profile is that it was
completely forested, top
to bottom, east to west.
Humans arrived.
And we know that humans
arrived around 2,000 years ago,
and that entirely as a
consequence of human arrival,
the deforestation occurred.
And then you see
this in anything
you read about Madagascar.
Only 10% of the
original forest remains.
Well, that relies
on this assumption
that it was entirely forested
before humans arrived.
Very recently, there have
been some publications showing
that grass actually arrived
in Madagascar about 23
million years ago.
So there's another new camp
that has just sort of popped up
in the literature that says,
hey, this grassland plateau is
ancient.
And it's been around
for 23 million years.
So what we see now is not
actually that different
from the natural environment.
And then there's
something sort of
in between-- the mosaic
hypothesis, which
is that yes, grasses
have been with us
for a long time in Madagascar.
But it has been this sort web
of forests on this plateau.
And this is this
mosaic hypothesis.
So if that is true--
I mean, we can
test this with genetic data.
So lehilahytsara now is living
in this kind of environment.
You saw that-- these little,
sinuous forest pieces.
And one can imagine
before human habitation
that there would have been
natural little forests, much
like Ankafobe all
throughout the plateau.
And if you have
continuous forest,
animals should be able to
move freely in any direction.
So it's more of a
diffusion model of gene
flow within the populations.
And we can test this
directly, and we have.
And I'm just going to
cut to the punchline.
So we have found that
lehilahytsara does, indeed,
show a very different
pattern of gene flow
relative to a sort
of diffusion model.
So it supports
the idea that they
have been living in a mosaic
environment for a long time,
meaning that humans were not
the intensely destructive agents
that we have inferred
them to be presently
in the traditional hypothesis.
Also, again, I'm
just jumping around--
this is complicated data.
But the geogenetic patterns
show that there was actually
sort of a bridge
across the island--
a genetic bridge
and that this occurred right
around 500,000 years ago.
So there have been
forests across Madagascar,
but over the past
500,000 years, they've
been breaking up
throughout the plateau.
And this summer, these
data will we published.
So stay tuned, if
you're interested.
OK, so just to summarize
that part of the talk--
so prior to human
arrival, there was
a mosaic of woodlands,
bushland, and open areas.
Fire from human
activities dramatically
transformed the landscape
at about 1,000 years ago.
We know that.
But forest fragments
comprised of endemic plants
and restricted to
valleys along streams
were isolated far earlier
than 1,000 years ago.
So this has been a natural part
of the Madagascar landscape.
And the forests have
been pulsing in response
to climate changes over
this long period of time,
thus depositing these very
distantly related mouse lemurs,
and then trapping them
in these little forests.
And then they pulse again.
And they reconnect.
So it's been this connection
and disconnection ongoing
for 100s of thousands of years.
So I just want to
acknowledge Team Mouse Lemur.
Everybody has been working
really hard on this project.
And it was announced
rather abruptly
that we were going to
do this in a hurry.
So Marina Blanco, Ryan Campbell,
Kelsie Hunnicutt, Peter Larson,
Dave Swafford, Dave
Weisrock-- want
to thank my funding sources--
NSP, the Helmsley Charitable
Trust, and the Duke Tropical
Conservation Initiative.
So those are the
acknowledgements.
Now, what does Google have
to do with any of this?
Well, a lot.
I mean, you've been seeing
me use Google Earth, which
has been my favorite
new toy to play with,
because I can say hey, is
there a forest corridor
between these two big forests?
Just Google Earth it, and
I get a good look at it.
It's just a remarkable tool.
So thank you for that.
And I've been reading
up on Google Loon, which
is just remarkable, if
ya'll can pull this off.
And if you just think
about what we're
trying to do in Madagascar--
training teachers
to train other teachers
and students-- so
we're very involved with
environmental education.
But you could see the
infrastructure in Madagascar
is not good.
So certainly in Tana,
yes, you have internet.
But if you get out into
the villages, which
is where our project is, you're
not going to get internet.
You can't go to
Starbucks and get Wi-Fi.
And certainly, if you're in the
field conducting your research,
you are offline for the entire
time that you're in the field.
So it would be really
magnificent to be able to tune
in, upload your data,
and work on a cloud,
or whatever you can imagine.
So this would be
very empowering.
But as my final slide,
I'm just going to ask you,
please, to hurry with this.
Because I live in a sort
of a rural community
outside of Chapel Hill.
We're in a green belt. And
the internet infrastructure
is about 15 years old out there.
And we have a
neighborhood listserv.
And you cannot believe the
complaining that goes on.
And we're fighting
with AT&T every day,
because we get these--
it's ridiculous
how awful our internet is.
And so I just copied from an
e-mail from one of my neighbors
last fall.
"227 Kbps right now.
Seriously?
I had work to do today."
So you can impact
people in Madagascar
and in the outskirts
of Chapel Hill when
you get Google Loon launched.
So that's it.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]